[Musique]
je
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
d' en séance les missions qui vous fait
vivre les débats de la haute assemblée
cet après midi vous allez suivre un
débat sur une proposition de loi
socialiste qui vise à renforcer le
plafonnement des frais bancaires je vous
laisse écouter les débats en déposant
cette proposition de loi au début de
l'année nous étions bien loin d'imaginer
l'intensité de la crise sanitaire dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons maintenant
ni les conséquences économiques et
sociales dramatiques qui frappent
désormais un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens car si notre pays connaît
une augmentation des inégalités sociales
depuis plusieurs années si la question
du pouvoir d'achat est au coeur des
préoccupations et du débat politique
depuis 2018
cette crise risque d'accentuer encore
bien davantage les disparités sociales
la précarité et les difficultés
financières des plus modestes
dès lors nous avons le devoir de définir
des mécanismes visant à contenir cette
dégradation en limitant autant que
possible la baisse du pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens
c'est pourquoi la question des frais
bancaires est aujourd'hui si importante
ils maintiennent la tête sous l'eau de
ceux qui sont déjà en difficulté et
nuisent directement à l'efficacité des
actions publiques menées pour les aider
à sortir de cette situation
dès lors il constitue un levier sur
lequel nous devons agir puisque nous en
avons la possibilité
c'est l'objet de cette proposition de
loi que j'ai l'honneur de présenter
aujourd'hui au nom du groupe socialiste
et républicain
la situation actuelle n'est plus
acceptable
ainsi l'association 60 millions de
consommateurs a considéré en 2018 que
les frais liés aux incidents de paiement
coûtait chaque année en moyenne 34 euros
à chaque français mais près de 300 euros
pour ceux qui étaient en difficulté
persistante
cette même étude montrait aussi qu'un
foyer en difficulté financière sur cinq
était prélevé à hauteur de 500 euros par
an au total si l'on compare ce montant à
la somme perçue par les bénéficiaires du
rsa ou bien au niveau du seuil de
pauvreté
il est difficile d'imaginer comment en
payant de tels frais bancaires les
personnes concernées peuvent s'en sortir
regardez par exemple l'aide
exceptionnelle de 200 euros que le
gouvernement a mis en place pour les
étudiants au mois de juin
elle servira souvent à peine à combler
les frais bancaires accumulées par ces
mêmes étudiants pendant cette période
cette à bairon en france en 2010 9 3,6
millions de personnes sont aujourd'hui
considérés comme en situation de
fragilité bancaire selon l'observatoire
de l'inclusion bancaire
ce sont autant de français qui auraient
dû bénéficier d'un plafonnement
effectifs des frais bancaires
car c'est peut-être le chiffre le plus
parlant plus de 90% des personnes qui
perçoivent moins de 1800 euros de
revenus mensuels c'est à dire le salaire
médian dans notre pays
pay plus de 40 euros de frais pour
incidents bancaires par mois alors nous
devons agir
je sais que nous sommes nombreux ici à
partager cette volonté est à notre avis
ce plafonnement doit être entendue au
sens large et pas seulement limitée aux
seuls incidents de paiement si nous
voulons avoir un impact fort sur le
pouvoir d'achat
à plusieurs reprises le gouvernement a
pris des engagements ces dernières
années en réponse à la crise dès gilet
jaune le président de la république lui
même a promis en décembre 2018 de
plafonner les frais bancaires pour les
plus fragiles de nos concitoyens car
dans la crise démocratique et sociale
qui venait de se déclencher avec tant de
violence
l'enjeu des frais bancaires était l'une
des revendications mises en avant avec
force et apparaissait comme l'un des
leviers sur lequel l'état pouvait agir
interrogé ici même par notre collègue
laurence rossignol en novembre dernier
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno le maire a réitéré ses
engagements
je les cite ses engagements plafonner
les incidents bancaires à 20 euros par
mois et 200 euros par an dans le cadre
de l'offre spécifique pour les personnes
les plus fragiles financièrement
augmenter le nombre de clients
bénéficiaire de cette offre spécifique
et plafonner les frais d'incidents
bancaire à 25 euros par mois pour les
personnes aux revenus modestes qui
n'aurait pas nécessairement besoin de
cette offre
force est de constater que ces mots
n'ont toujours pas été suivie d'effet et
pour cause la bonne volonté du
gouvernement est moins grande que la
mauvaise volonté des banques
ainsi dans l'examen du projet de loi
prorogeant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le gouvernement a fait supprimer
l'amendement qui avait été présenté par
le groupe socialiste et qui visait à
protéger les ménages les plus fragiles
des frais et commissions pour incidents
bancaires pendant la période d'urgence
sanitaire un amendement pourtant très
largement adopté par le sénat et écoutez
bien l'exposé des motifs du gouvernement
dans son amendement de suppression à
l'assemblée
cette disposition pourrait créer des
effets d'aubaine importants ou susciter
des effets indésirables notamment en
réduisant les incitations à honorer
certains paiements dus c'est de cette
logique punitive qu'il faut sortir car
elle enfonce les plus fragiles et les
plus pauvres et plus largement tous ceux
dont les revenus couvre à peine les
dépenses incontournables même le
ministre olivier ferrand a reconnu à
l'assemblée qui est je le cite il ne
l'aurait pas écrit ainsi et il a
regretté ces mots qui n'ont pas à
figurer dans un exposé sommaire quand il
s'agit de frais bancaires pour des
personnes précaires j'ai envie de vous
demander madame la ministre
mais qui a donc exposé écrit cet exposé
des motifs
depuis bruno le maire a de nouveau
déclaré qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
renforcer le cadre légal existant sur
les frais bancaires
dans une déclaration faite 48 heures
après le dépôt de cette proposition de
loi son inscription à l'ordre du jour
heureuse coïncidence c'est pour mettre
fin à ces tergiversations qu'avec le
président kamerhe mes collègues mes
collègues du groupe socialiste et
républicain
nous avons déposé cette proposition de
loi
un texte qui s'il ne répond pas à toutes
les problématiques permettra néanmoins
s'il est adopté dans traiter une partie
importante
je ne veux pas être trop long sur le
dispositif lui-même je sais que le
rapporteur michel canevet tu reviendras
dessus je tiens d'ailleurs à le
remercier pour son travail au nom de la
commission des finances mais que prévoit
dans les grandes lignes notre
proposition de loi
d'abord en modifiant le code monétaire
et financier son article unique vise à
intégrer dans les plafonnements définies
par décret la problématique des frais
bancaires
nous l'avons dit connaissent une
croissance très soutenue ces dernières
années et servent beaucoup trop
aujourd'hui aux établissements bancaires
de variable d'ajustement pour leurs
marges sommes perçues qui représente au
total de l'ordre de 30 milliards d'euros
par an je ne parle pas seulement des
frais pour incidents bancaires mais des
frais pour l'ensemble des services
bancaires ainsi les plafonnements
s'appliquerait à la fois aux sommes
perçues par les banques pour les
incidents de paiement et pour les
différents et très nombreux services
bancaires proposées par les
établissements
si notre proposition de loi est adopté
bien entendu ensuite nous proposons que
les plafonds spécifiques dont peuvent
bénéficier les personnes en situation de
fragilité bancaire atteignent au maximum
le tiers du plafond général existants il
s'agit là d'un enjeu important sur le
plan social social éviter que les plus
modestes soit ce qui en réalité
contribuent le plus comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
enfin dans la mesure où il est avéré que
les établissements bancaires ne sont pas
suffisamment coopératifs en matière de
reconnaissance des personnes en
situation de fragilité qui l'ont
toujours l'interprétation la plus
restrictive possible nous voulons ouvrir
aux présidents de conseil départemental
centre communal intercommunal d'action
sociale ainsi qu'à la banque de france
la possibilité d'exiger d'un
établissement bancaire
l'application du statut de personnes en
situation de fragilité car ce que nous
constatons aujourd'hui c'est une
interprétation beaucoup trop
restrictives de la part des banques et
certains qu'ils devraient
certains bénéficiaires qui devrait en
relever il échappe
la plupart en bénéficient trop
tardivement et en sortent ensuite trop
rapidement rendant largement inopérante
7 ce qui est un progrès de l'offre
spécifique mais qui est aujourd'hui
beaucoup trop limité par la pratique par
ailleurs et enfin une fois n'est pas
coutume le groupe socialiste a déposé
des amendements sur son propre texte
ces amendements visent à prendre en
compte la situation de crise sanitaire
qui est apparue après le dépôt du texte
comme je le disais en introduction
ces modifications permettront d'inclure
les citoyens les plus durement touchés
par la crise dans les dispositions que
nous proposons d'adapter et ce comme
nous l'avons déjà voté lors de l'examen
du projet de loi prorogeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
j'espère que le sénat confirmera son
engagement dans ce sens
comme il l'a fait malgré l'avis
défavorable du gouvernement à une très
large majorité il ya tout juste deux
semaines
mes chers collègues l'urgence sociale
nous impose de ne pas renoncer dans
cette crise encore plus qu'hier nous
avons le devoir de protéger les plus
modestes avant les bénéfices réalisés
par les banques sur ce sujet des frais
bancaires si important pour les français
nous avons déjà beaucoup attendu alors
il n'est plus temps d'attendre
d'attendre encore mais de changer les
choses vraiment et donc de légiférer
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
pas la discussion générale la parole est
à monsieur michel canevet rapporteur de
la commission des finances pour dix
minutes un bien monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la commission des finances monsieur
le rapporteur général de la commission
des finances mes chers collègues je
voudrais tout d'abord remercier le
groupe socialiste et spécifiquement rémi
féraud qui connaît parfaitement ce sujet
pour avoir proposé 7
ce texte de loi effectivement qui risque
qui vise à rendre effectif way et à
renforcer le plafonnement des frais
bancaires
c'est un sujet important vous le savez
tous ces questions de frais bancaires
ont fait l'objet de différents textes
depuis un certain nombre d'années
notamment la loi de séparation de
régulation bancaire du 26 juillet 2013 à
instituer des mesures de plafonnement
pour ce qu'ils ont à faire face à des
incidents de paiement des irrégularités
alors il faut signaler que en france
nous avons la chance d'avoir un réseau
bancaire qu'ils soient particulièrement
important qui soit dense
il est constitué d'un grand nombre
d'institutions financières plus de 100
institutions financières qui offrent des
produits très diversifiés et variées ce
qui permet effectivement à la clientèle
d'opérer des choix des choix quant aux
services qu'ils peuvent en attendre ceci
est important c'est un contexte
important aussi et nous sommes tous
particulièrement attaché à ce que cette
présence bancaire se poursuivent en
particulier pour ce qui concerne le
réseau sur le territoire composé d'un
grand nombre d'agents ce dont on déplore
parfois d'ailleurs la réduction la
diminution on le déplore aussi pour ce
qui concerne les distributeurs
automatiques de billets et à plusieurs
reprises notamment sur le groupe de
groupe des indépendants a eu l'occasion
de déposer des textes tendance à faire
en sorte de trouver des dispositifs
permettant d'améliorer cette offre
concernant les distributeurs de billets
c'est dire que que donc l'institution
l'institution financière ont un rôle et
une place importante dans notre pays
et si ce texte a été déposé avant la
situation de crise pandémique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
effectivement la situation de crise
pandémie pandémique a entraîné une autre
vision peut-être une autre approche de
ces institutions financières et il me
faut quand même dire et rappeler que si
les choses se font pas trop mal passé au
niveau financier c'est parce que les
établissements financiers ont su faire
preuve de célérité et de simplicité dans
la mise en oeuvre d'un certain nombre de
dispositions je pense en particulier au
dispositif des prêts garantis par l'état
pour ce qui concerne le secteur
économique qui a quand même il faut le
dire étaient mises en oeuvre
dans des délais extrêmement bref avec
des taux d'acceptation qui sont très
élevés montrant que le dispositif
fonctionne bien et les institutions
financières se sont également attachés à
prendre diverses dispositions qui pour
la beaucoup ont été suggérées par le
gouvernement d'ailleurs pour ce qui
concerne des reports d'échéances par
exemple et certainement aussi une
attention beaucoup plus bienveillante au
situation d'irrégularité et d'incidents
de paiement en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne les prêts qui pourrait en être
facturés compte tenu de la situation que
nous connaissons et donc il faut prendre
cela en compte à mon avis est bien être
conscient que finalement nous avons eu
la chance d'avoir ce réseau bancaire
particulièrement efficient alors le
texte qui nous est proposé évoque
effectivement les personnes en situation
de fragilité financière sont évalués à 3
millions 3 millions 3,3 millions 6,2
personnes en france c'est à dire ce sont
des personnes qui sont soient inscrits
au fichier des incidents de paiement
c'est-à-dire qui pendant trois mois
consécutifs ont en plus à faire face à
des paiements pour les chèques par
exemple ou bien ce sont des personnes
qui sont aussi dans le site dans le
dispositif des situations de
surendettement
celles là sont automatiquement considéré
comme étant en fragilité financière
et puis les établissements financiers
ont aussi leurs propres critères pour
définir les personnes en situation de
fragilité financière à partir du niveau
de ressources ou à partir d' incidents
de paiement répétitif qui sont observés
et dans ce cas donc sont mises en oeuvre
comme je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure et
comme rémi féraud là aussi précisé des
dispositifs qui permettent de limiter
les frais en l'occurrence
4 8 euros par part opération à 80 euros
par mois pour les clients lambda je
dirais puis pour ceux qui ont souscrit
l'offre spécifique l'offre spécifique
étant une offre qui comprend un nombre
de service minimum mais qui a été
instituée depuis 2014 qui a beaucoup
augmenté puisque 380 mille personnes en
ont bénéficié jusqu'en 2018 et puis en
2019 il y eut une augmentation tout à
fait qu'on significative du nombre de
bénéficiaires de cette offre spécifique
puisque le total est de 485 milles
aujourd'hui c'est à dire
approximativement 15% des personnes qui
peuvent être considérés en situation de
fragilité financière et donc pour cette
offre spécifique il y à un plafonnement
à 4 euros par opération et à 20 euros
par mois en totale pour les personnes
qui qui en bénéficient donc on voit
qu'il y a des dispositions qui existent
et qui ont montré tout leur intérêt
alors la proposition de loi elle vise à
intégrer dans ses plafonnement pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
l'ensemble des coûts bancaires c'est à
dire les frais incidents et services
bancaires alors moi je suis de ceux qui
considèrent que pour autant qu'il faille
regarder les choses précisément il ne
faut pas qu'on remettra encore mettent
en cause notre système bancaire français
qui est particulièrement opérant si l'on
veut réduire les moyens des banques
il faudra ensuite ne pas s'étonner que
les banques soient conduites à réduire
le réseau d'agents ce voir les
personnels voire à dématérialiser comme
cela se constate pour beaucoup
effectivement donc il faut quand même
dire que la banque a besoin de garder
des personnes qui sont en relation avec
les clients et qui ont un rôle de
conseil
vers les clients ça c'est important
et donc pour cela je crois qu enfin la
commission des finances a estimé que
qu'il n'était pas souhaitable de retenir
la proposition présentée dans dans le
texte par le groupe socialiste
et puis un autre point était également
évoqué concernant l'offre spécifique que
je viens d'évoquer
à l'instant pour considérer que il leur
était possible à la banque de france aux
présidents des conseils départementaux
des centres communaux et intercommunaux
d'action sociale d'enjoindre les
établissements financiers à ouvrir des
comptes au titre de l'offre si fiq pour
les clients alors je suis aussi de ceux
qui considèrent que nous sommes dans un
pays où la responsabilité individuelle
existe et il ne faut pas faire des
choses à la place des gens à la place
des autres
il faut c'est le rôle des services
sociaux que de les accompagner dans un
certain nombre de démarches mais pas de
se substituer à aux droits et libertés
de chacun et donc je crois qu'il faut
que chacun reste à sa place et en ce
sens il n'est pas apparu non plus à la
commission des finances qu'il était
opportun de pouvoir institué ce
dispositif
il existe par exemple pour ce qui
concerne le droit au compte mais force
est de constater qu'ils sont très peu
usité puisque je crois qu'en 2018 il ya
eu 2 2 deux interventions pour cela au
titre de l'ensemble des droits comme
c'est à dire que ce type de dispositif
qui part de très bonnes intentions bien
souvent
n'a pas n'a pas d'intérêt à exister donc
il faut que l'on que l'on puisse être
dans une démarche d'accompagnement pour
ceux qui ont des problèmes c'est le rôle
des banques
c'est aussi le rôle des points conseils
budget qui ont été initiées depuis 2016
moi j'invite le gouvernement approuve
continuer à lancer des appels à projet
en ce sens puisque un objectif de 400
points conseils budget avait été
instituée au départ et puis on n'y est
pas encore je crois que c'est 150 une
certaine oui voilà qui qui existent
aujourd'hui donc il est souhaitable que
ces points conseils budget puisse se
développer sur le territoire parce que
c'est aussi un moyen que pour permettre
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens en
situation de fragilité financière de
pouvoir mieux gérer leur compte car
finalement quand on parle d'incidents de
paiement et de frais à régler
à ce titre ce sont aussi des outils qui
permettent peut-être un certain nombre
d'entre nous de mieux gérer leur
situation financière parce que certains
ont du mal à gérer leur compte et le
fait qu'il y est c'est fait les amène
sans doute pas à devoir réfléchir en ce
sens et amène aussi puisqu'une attention
et porté là dessus
les banquiers à s'intéresser à les
accompagner pour cela et puis j'aurai
terminé en saluant l'initiative que le
gouvernement avait prise en 2018 et puis
tout récemment pour inciter des
établissements bancaires à avoir une
approche beaucoup plus rigide sur le
sujet c'est-à-dire à contingenter le
niveau des frais bancaires
on voit que ça donne des résultats et il
faut continuer ainsi
merci c'est le rapporteur dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
madame la ministre madame agnès pannier
rues de chez secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le débat à la
concertation sont indispensables à la
vie démocratique et c'est d'abord et
c'est d'ailleurs la méthode que nous
avons suivie depuis le début du
quinquennat et que nous suivons pour
trouver les meilleures solutions
possibles au bénéfice de nos concitoyens
et pour répondre aux attentes et
apporter des solutions concrètes
c'est notamment le cas sur la maîtrise
des frais bancaires il s'agit d'un sujet
important dans un contexte où nombre de
nos concitoyens sont concernés par une
dégradation de la situation économique
et sociale
ce gouvernement a mis en place un
plafonnement des frais d'incident
bancaires en faveur des publics fragiles
ce plafonnement il est effectif pour les
clientèles fragiles et il permet de
soutenir nos concitoyens en difficulté
dans la période actuelle
c'est un sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement a pris des mesures fortes
ne sont pas des promesses cd c'est
désormais effectif
la première étape c'est septembre 2018
nous avons conclu un accord avec le
secteur bancaire pour plafonner les
frais d'incidents à 20 euros par mois
il ya 200 euros par an pour les publics
bénéficiaires de l'offre dite clients
fragiles
cette offre spécifique prévue par la loi
de piles 2014 garantit l'accès aux
services bancaires de base à un prix
modique
nous avions également fixé l'objectif
d'une progression de 30% du nombre de
personnes bénéficiant de cette offre
soit environ 300 mille bénéficiaires
supplémentaires à l'époque deuxième
étape en décembre 2018 nous avons élargi
le principe du plafonnement à tous les
clients identifiées comme fragiles
financièrement permettant un plus de 3
millions de personnes d'être éligibles
au dispositif
les banques se sont engagées au
président du président de la république
a plafonné à 25 euros par mois et 300
euros par an les frais d'incidents
bancaire pour tous les clients
financièrement fragiles ces mesures sont
importantes car elles fonctionnent
aujourd'hui pour les français touchés
par la crise le dispositif que nous
avons mis en place a démontré son
efficacité pour réduire les frais
d'incident des personnes en fragilité
financière ses engagements comme vous le
savez sont suivis et contrôlée depuis
2019 par la dgccrf
l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution et l'observatoire de
l'inclusion bancaire des contrôles de la
cpr et la dgccrf ont ainsi été a
diligenté à partir de mi 2010
aff sur cette base nous avons réalisé un
bilan de l'application du plafonnement
en février dernier il en ressort que les
ago jugement pris par les banques en
matière de plafonnement bien été
respectées ainsi le plafond mensuel de
25 euros de frais d'incidents bancaire
est appliquée à 3,3 millions de clients
il a permis une diminution des frais
pour plus d'un million de clients et de
nos concitoyens enfin en 2010 9 490
mille personnes ont bénéficié de l'offre
spécifique contre 381 me fin 2010 est il
donc nous avons constaté une progression
de plus de cent mille personnes en
quelques mois ces résultats sont
significatifs sur la base de ce bilan
nous avons amélioré le dispositif pour
répondre aux attentes des différentes
parties prenantes en février 2020 nous
avons complété le dispositif
nous avons obtenu l'engagement des
grandes entreprises émettrices de
factures de déployer d'ici à la fin
d'année 2021 des solutions afin que les
prélèvements infructueux qui sont
représentés et qui donc peuvent générer
plusieurs fois des frais soient
automatiquement identifié cela permet
d'éviter l'application répétées de frais
liés à la représentation d'un
prélèvement infructueux ces entreprises
ont également proposé à leurs clients la
possibilité de choisir librement les
dates de prélèvement pour prévenir les
accidents de trésorerie d'autres
améliorations inspiré de discussions
concrètes avec les acteurs de terrain
vont être mises en oeuvre dans les
prochaines semaines dans le cadre de la
discussion du projet de loi sur la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avait d'ailleurs indiqué bruno
le maire s'est engagé à améliorer la
définition de la fragilité financière
qui conditionne l'accès à l'offre
bancaire spécifique et au plafonnement
des frais d'incident cette évolution
vise à permettre aux personnes fragiles
de bénéficier plus rapidement des effets
du plafonnement aujourd'hui ces trois
mois il décide de déclencher plus
rapidement ce repérage des personnes
fragiles nous allons également renforcer
la transparence sur l'application par
chacun des établissements de crédit du
plafonnement et sur les résultats
concrets de son application
donc vous le voyez non seulement le
dispositif existe il est effectif et les
résultats sont au rendez vous
cela démontre en méthode qui n'est pas
besoin de passer par la contrainte
législative pour parvenir à des
résultats concrets et puissants et que
cela permet de constamment améliorer le
dispositif en s'appuyant sur les
remontées terrain
nous proposons donc pragmatiquement de
poursuivre dans cette voie car là est
démontré son efficacité
au delà de cette question méthode nous
avons une divergence de fond avec le
dispositif qui est proposée par cette
proposition doit car en réalité le texte
de la proposition humaine n'est pas en
accord avec l'exposé des motifs
en effet le texte prévoit un
plafonnement de l'ensemble des frais
bancaires passe eu d'incident pour
toutes les clientèles
quelle que soit leur situation de
revenus et de patrimoine ce qui nous
semble pas complètement pertinents il
nous semble difficile de défendre un
plafonnement généralisée qui
s'appliquerait de manière indiscriminée
aux frais d'incidents aux frais de
fonctionnement norvo mot qui vient de
rémunérer des prestations habituelles
fournies par les établissements
bancaires il nous sommes difficile de
défendre l'extension en clientèle plus
aisée d'un dispositif de plafonnement
qui a été créée en réalité pour les
clients fragiles comme vous l'avez bien
défendu dans vous prises de parole il
n'y a rien d'anormal car clients
effectuant de nombreuses transactions
bancaires disposant de moyens financiers
conséquents paye des frais et notamment
en cas d'incident le cas échéant parce
qu'on peut estimer que il suffisamment
organisés pour éviter ces situations
en outre un plafonnement généralisée
aurait des effets collatéraux
contre-productif l'avait très bien à
expliquer en plafonnant tous les prix
pour toutes les clientèles nous risquons
inciter les établissements à ne plus
proposer certains services qui peuvent
l'être aujourd'hui de manière quasi
gratuite comme la mise à disposition de
chéquier nous pourrions les inciter
aussi à renchérir d'autres produits pour
les retrouver de la marge des crédits à
la consommation les crédits immobiliers
une telle contrainte risquerait enfin
d'accélérer certaines réorganisation des
réseaux bancaires ce qui pourrait nuire
à la continuité territoriale de l'offre
bancaire et de la densité des réseaux à
laquelle je sais que votre assemblée est
à juste titre sensible
j'ajoute enfin que cette proposition est
ré à l'encontre du développement de
services innovants car dans le secteur
bancaire
le développement d'offres alternatives
favorise le consommateur je pense
notamment au nez aux banques qui font
aujourd'hui partie intégrante du paysage
bancaire pour nombre de nos concitoyens
et qui permettent d'accéder à un coût
très faible à des services bancaires de
qualité mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous l'aurez compris nous ne
soutiendrons pas ses propositions loi
qui tant sur la méthode que sur les
propositions formulées n'améliorera pas
la situation des plus fragiles
sur le sujet des frais bancaires le
dispositif de plafonnement des frais
d'incidents qui a mis en place ce
gouvernement en lien avec le secteur
bancaire et les associations protège nos
concitoyens touchés par la fragilité
financière
nous allons poursuivre la mise en oeuvre
de cette méthode fondée sur le terrain
d'un concertation qui a démontré son
efficacité car ce qu'attendaient les
français et particulièrement dans cette
période difficile
ce sont avant tout des résultats c'est
ainsi que nous répondrons réellement aux
défis sociale qui est devant nous je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à monsieur jean françois husson pour le
groupe l'est républicain pour cinq
minutes un monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues nous
discutons donc aujourd'hui de la
proposition de loi du groupe socialiste
visant à renforcer le plafonnement des
frais bancaires
des observateurs peut être cynique
peuvent-ils voir ou où il devinait une
scène qui semble écrite d'avancé lors de
ce duel annoncé entre les consommateurs
et en particulier les plus modestes
aient les banques chaque côté de
l'hémicycle y trouvera un camps
différents à défendre avec des acteurs
très style ancien monde
en fait c'est pas du tout de ça dont il
s'agit c'est la raison pour laquelle je
remercie notre rapporteur ainsi que
dépositaire de la proposition de loi
d'avoir néanmoins posé le problème
soyons précis qu'un service proposé est
un coup quoi de plus normal le jeu de la
concurrence empêche leurs excès mais mon
inquiétude se situe moins au niveau du
prix des services qu'à celui des frais
d'incident bancaire s'il me semble
bienvenue de rappeler que le coût de
gestion d'un incident de paiement n'est
pas juste pour la banque
le prix du timbre poste utilisé pour
envoyer la lettre aux clients est il
acceptable de constater que les citoyens
les plus
fragiles financièrement sont ceux qui
sont susceptibles de payer le plus de
frais bancaires ce qui peut les
entraîner dans une spirale sans fin
non nous refusons de nous résoudre à
cette situation mes chers collègues ce
texte contient cependant des
imperfections manifeste outre les
questions juridiques
le plafonnement proposez apparaît à bien
des égards
excessifs ne serait ce que parce qu'il
vise l'ensemble des français alors que
la problématique des frais bancaires
pour être résolus se doit d'avoir une
approche plus fine
quant à la suppression dudit frais
proposée par l'auteur et les auteurs de
la ppl durant cette crise sanitaire
elle a certes le mérite d'envoyer un
signal fort dans sa forme mais ne résout
en rien le problème de fond c'est
peut-être même le contraire je suis
d'ailleurs plus enclins à la gratuité
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres
parce que c'est une forme de l'heure ce
qui est gratuit est toujours un coût qui
est supporté par d'autres et en plus il
y as derrière tous un effet
déresponsabilisant je crois qu'il faut
lier ce débat à celui du modèle
économique des banques dans son ensemble
notamment dans un contexte de taux bas
les prêts ne rapporteraient plus aux
banques
et il faudrait trouver de l'argent
ailleurs dans le retrait d'espèces on
sait malheureusement contre les zones
blanches est la surabondance dans
certains endroits de distributeurs
bancaires
il y a là aussi bien des injustices ne
resterait-il alors que les frais
bancaires pour survivre non assurément
raisonnement simpliste qui doit nous
interpeller
et je le dis un plafonnement aveugle
déplacera vous déplacerez simplement le
problème et demain peut-être que nous
aurions droit à nouveau une proposition
de loi socialiste pour demander la
présence de l'état dans une étape de
transformation pour pas dire de
désengagement territoriale des banques
je crois que le ciblage plus fin la
détection plus rapide des publics
vulnérables à qui l'on pourrait ainsi
réduire fortement la charge des frais
bancaires pour leur éviter la spirale
que je viens d'évoquer tout à l'heure
sans bouleverser le mode et les comics
acteur bancaire apparaît comme une piste
intéressante
nous avons eu l'occasion de rappeler
le taux de souscription de l'offre
spécifique n'excédait pas 15% des
clients éligibles
faut-il alors réformer le fonctionnement
d'un outil considéré comme trop rigides
pour ses détenteurs la question est
posée mais il est toujours délicat de
faire en sorte que l'offre spécifique ne
soit pas perçue comme une étiquette
punitive et stigmatisantes sans pour
autant en faire un statut comme un autre
alors qu'elle signifie pour le client
qui via une fragilité face à ce dilemme
il a été rappelé les engagements forts
négocié avec le secteur bancaire depuis
la crise des gilets jaunes dont acte en
effet oui nous devons apprécier ces
avancées qui aurait bénéficié ça vient
d'être dit madame la ministre à un
million de clients supplémentaires
profitons alors de ce texte pour
traduire dans la loi les engagements
mise en oeuvre et obtenu depuis 18 mois
sur les frais bancaires
la loi étant par définition moins
perméable aux aléas du contexte général
notre rapporteur michel canevet dont je
salue ici à nouveau le travail propose
de profiter de l'examen de ce texte pour
propres pour porter les améliorations
qui repose sur une logique importante la
transparence une transparence qui
apparaît nécessaire ne serait-ce qu'au
regard de la difficulté de percevoir le
réel montant acquitté par les français
s'agissant des frais d'incident bancaire
chaque année on sait que derrière
l'opacité les règles de l'art elle
concurrence des marchés sont vite
distordue un terrain qui profite à
certains abus mes chers collègues je
pense que l'esprit de responsabilité du
sénat doit et peu imprégnés ce sujet
épineux trop souvent me semble-t-il
réduits à la caricature du banquier qui
se garaient sur le dos des plus modestes
sachons tenir le débat au bon niveau en
évitant tout excès parce que derrière
les mots se cache des réalités tellement
différente est digne d'intérêt que nous
devons éviter de caricaturer ou de les
traiter à la légère collègues à la suite
de la discussion générale la par l'état
au président patrick kanner pour le
groupe socialiste pour cinq minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain la
crise que nous traversons n'est pas que
sanitaire et économique c'est aussi une
bombe sociale à fragmentation qui nous
attend les mesures prises par le
gouvernement puis de moine anticipa
malgré nos multiples alertes cette
situation dégradée qui attend notre pays
qui risque de s'installer pour de
nombreuses années
certes cette proposition de loi a été
pensé bien avant que nous puissions
imaginez la situation actuelle certes la
problématique des frais bancaires est
bien antérieure à la crise que nous
vivons notre texte aurait tout pc utt
pardon pertinent il ya six mois il ya
deux ans voire plus et sûrement plus
encore je dois le dire ici même si c'est
une évidence
le dispositif que nous proposons est
encore plus opportun aujourd'hui j'ai
bien entendu les remarques de monsieur y
sont les les amendements qui ne
manqueront pas d'être votée à l'occasion
de notre débat mais c'est un texte
d'interpellations est manifestement cela
a réussi et nous en sommes très heureux
nous le savons mes chers collègues
l'histoire est là pour le rappeler les
crises sociales n'accouche que rarement
d'un monde d'après plus fraternelle plus
solidaire et donc il nous appartient de
veiller à ce que cette solidarité soit
dans les faits si nous ne faisons rien
cette crise sera comme les autres
les plus fragiles seront durement frappé
les inégalités augmenteront une partie
de la classe moyenne basculera dans la
précarité et le populisme progressera la
tâche est donc colossal deux mois de
quasi arrêt de l'économie des échanges
internationaux au plus bas une confiance
des ménages très faible vont
mécaniquement provoqué une hausse du
chômage une baisse des revenus pour de
nombreux français les chiffres de pôle
emploi aujourd'hui sont terribles
cela ne pourrait être évitée mais cela
doit être réduit le plus possible dans
ses conséquences pour cela l'urgence la
plus absolue doit être décrétée par le
pouvoir exécutif est malheureusement ce
n'est pas le cas des mesures d'urgence
ont bien été prises pour faire face au
confinement pour accompagner le d
confinement des aides ponctuelles
ciblées ont été débloqués je les salue
madame la ministre
mais les enjeux sont bien plus larges et
le thermomètre de l'explosion de la
demande alimentaire doit plus que nous
alerter oui l'urgence est à l'action sur
le front social convoqué l'esprit du
conseil national de la résistance comme
l'a fait à plusieurs reprises le
président de la république ne suffit pas
il faut agir et mettre en place en
urgence d'un nouveau pacte social
national pour amortir l'effet de la
crise sociale et sanitaire
sinon mes chers collègues je vous le dis
ce ne sont pas des jours heureux qui
nous attendent mais des jours désastreux
le groupe socialiste et républicain du
sénat compte sur la haute assemblée pour
débuter le travail dès maintenant en
votant cette proposition de loi
sûrement amende et j'espère que le
gouvernement à la lumière de ces
éléments et de la dégradation de la
situation sociale se montrera plus
ouvert qu'il cesse été rappelé par notre
collègue rémi féraud qu'il cesse de
qualifier d' effets d'aubaine la
limitation de ses frais cette prise de
position est calamiteuse et porte
atteinte à la dignité des français les
plus en difficulté l'exécutif doit
changer le ton et de position
actuellement comme nous l'avons signalé
il se contente de demander aux banques
davantage d'autorégulation il semble
donc placé la défense et la liberté
d'action du secteur bancaire comme une
priorité plutôt que d'agir en direction
des 80 % de nos concitoyens en situation
d'endettement qui dans les faits ne
bénéficie d'aucun plafonnement en
permettant aux banques de jouer le rôle
de gendarme et parfois de voleurs il
renforce les inégalités sociales la
situation est grave
actuellement près de la moitié de la
population active subi une perte
substantielle de ses revenus en se
retrouvant au chômage partiel et risque
de rejoindre la cohorte des français
précaire asphyxiés par les frais
toujours plus importants nous avons donc
décidé que cette limitation des frais
bancaires ne devait pas concerner c'est
vrai seulement le plus fragile mais
également les français qui subissent une
perte de revenu temporaire en raison de
la crise temporaire en raison de la
crise notre dispositif de limitation de
ses frais permet de réguler un domaine
qui ne l'est pas assez et de desserrer
l'étau qui empêchent de nombreuses
familles de sortir la tête de l'eau
pour quelques centaines d'euros ce n'est
plus la pression des ronds points qui
doivent pousser malama ministre à agir
dans ce domaine
mais la lutte contre le cataclysme
social qui est devant nous avec le
groupe socialiste républicain nous
pensons que la république est légitime
quand elle est sociale ce n'est pas un
effet de tribune que de le dire il faut
regarder les choses en face si nous ne
faisons rien la désespérance ne sera pas
que social mes chers collègues elle sera
aussi démocratique et entraînera des
conséquences que chacun connaît bien ici
et mesure aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues vous allez pouvoir d'agir pour
le pouvoir de vivre alors ensemble
sachons saisir cette opportunité que
nous avons essayé de vous présenter
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est au
président jean marc gabouty pour le
groupe rds pour sept minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur rapporteur rendre
effectif et renforcer le plafonnement
des frais bancaires est une démarche qui
pourrait recueillir une très large
adhésion au parlement et sans doute être
plébiscité un dante par nos compatriotes
ces initiatives relève d'une bonne
intention elle peut avoir son utilité
dans notre réflexion sur un tel sujet
avant de se propose de prononcer sur ce
que propose ce texte il convient de
rappeler la situation du secteur
bancaire et certaines caractéristiques
de son fonctionnement et de son
évolution
le modèle bancaire a changé au cours de
la dernière décennie avec un produit net
bancaire en légère diminution - 3 % par
exemple entre 2009 et 2016 et un
équilibre de ses composantes qui s'est
sensiblement modifié si les banques se
trouvent aujourd'hui parfois concurrencé
par d'autres acteurs comme sur les
moyens de paiement leurs fondamentaux
historiques près activités de marché
c'est à dire les placements financiers
commission résiste bien
cependant ils ne sont plus des vecteurs
aussi dynamique par le passé ce qui a
conduit le secteur bancaire lui aussi à
ce défi à se diversifier
comme sur le marché de l'assurance cette
appréciation prudente de la solidité des
perspectives de ce secteur ne nous
exonère cependant pas d'examiner la
pertinence des méthodes et des niveaux
de frais bancaires surtout pour ceux
auxquels la loi peut conférer une base
légale
par ailleurs il faut bien reconnaître
que l'ensemble des commissions frais
pénalité représente souvent un vrai
maquis dans lequel les clients souvent
ont du mal à se retrouver et avec une
transparence qui demeure toujours en
petits caractères mais avec cette
proposition de loi
nous nous intéressons - au secteur
bancaire ou financier qu'à ses clients
en particulier les plus modestes
c'est à dire ceux qui sont souvent les
plus vulnérables dans la gestion de
leurs revenus et leurs dépenses
il est vrai que ces personnes fragiles
mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
particuliers travailleurs indépendants
artisans commerçants petites et moyennes
entreprises sont confrontées
chacun à leur niveau aux mêmes
difficultés face aux frais bancaires ce
qui peut les entraîner dans une spirale
infernale pour les uns mais profitable
pour les autres ainsi l'imputation des
frais pénalité du mois précédent sur un
compte peut mettre celui-ci en découvert
loin des dépassements d'autorisation
générant ainsi de nouveaux impayés et le
déclenchement de nouveaux frais
bancaires c'est le système de la cascade
qui petit à petit permet à certains
clients de creuser leur trou du moins
celui de leurs comptes
la facturation globale du découvert
bancaire représentait bien 6.5 milliards
d'euros de revenus en 2016 dont 4,9
milliards de bénéfices soit 16 % du
résultat net des banques françaises qui
s'est levé comme cela a été dit par rémi
féraud à 34 milliards d'euros mais c'est
le bénéfice total toutes activités
confondues et
ces 6 milliards de revenus et 4 9
milliards de bénéfices ne sont pas
nécessairement supporté par les
catégories les plus modestes mais sont
principalement supportée probablement
par le secteur des pme tpe et
travailleurs indépendants
donc voilà il faut mettre des chiffres
en face aussi de ce qu'il est qui les
supportent donc j'adhère je dirais à la
démarche au niveau de la réflexion du
projet de loi
pour autant je ne ferai pas l'avocat de
la proposition telle qu'elle est rédigée
pour deux raisons essentielles
elle me paraît d'une part trop générales
sur la notion de frais bancaires et
d'autre part trop ciblée sur les publics
concernés
sur le premier point en terme de frais
bancaires il convient de bien faire la
différence entre ce qui relève du
contrat ou une prestation de services
soumis naturellement à la libre
concurrence et c'est peut-être ce qui
nous différencie avec la proposition du
groupe socialiste et les pénalités
même si parfois elle porte un autre nom
qui peuvent justifier un encadrement par
la loi ou la réglementation
il convient donc d'agir plus sur les
principes et sur les pratiques que sur
le niveau des commissions des
rémunérations sur le second point le
périmètre ne doit pas être limitée aux
seuls publics en difficulté qui
bénéficient déjà de protection tel que
cela a été rappelé par des ministres car
il n'y a aucune raison que les
limitations ou l'encadrement et un
caractère pro catégorielles suivant des
normes qui ressemblerait alors à celle
d'une caisse d'allocations familiales
plus qu'à celle d'une banque tutelle
publique ou mutualistes
bien évidemment ce sont les personnes
modestes qui rend compte pour de
multiples raisons des difficultés qui
devraient être les premières
bénéficiaires de nouvelles limitations
protection qu'il convient cependant de
définir et d'adopter de manière plus
générique
dans ces conditions et en remerciant les
auteurs cette proposition de loi
ainsi que le rapporteur pour hommes son
analyse et ses propositions de nous
avoir permis de développer une réflexion
sur ce sujet et je me rallierai ainsi
que le groupe rdse dans un souci
d'efficacité
à la proposition de nouvelle rédaction
de l'article unique proposée par notre
rapporteur
merci sur collègues dans la suite de la
discussion la parole et à monsieur
xavier iacovelli pour la république en
marche pour sept minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur donc
je salue le travail chers collègues
la question des tarifs pratiqués par les
établissements bancaires a fait l'objet
d'une grande attention depuis plusieurs
mois je crois que c'est une
préoccupation partagée par toutes les
couleurs politiques et je remercie nos
collègues du groupe socialiste d'avoir
inscrit cette proposition de loi à
l'occasion de l'ordre du jour qui leur
est réservé dans les termes de redu
règlement de notre assemblée la question
comme les choses de la vie a toute sa
place dans le débat parlementaire
les associations de consommateurs
estiment nous l'avons dit à près de 6,5
milliards les frais payés par les
françaises et les français aux
établissements bancaires
ce chiffre comporte des disparités au
niveau individuel les clients en
difficulté financière perse persistant
se voient prélever près de 300 euros de
frais par an contre huit à neuf fois
moins 34 euros pour l'ensemble des
clients en moyenne même si les chiffres
ne sont pas objectives et faute de
données fiables les ordres de grandeur
sont représentatifs de la situation des
français
cette question a fait l'objet de
plusieurs depuis plusieurs années d'une
grande attention
depuis 2007 les tarifs bancaires liées
aux incidents de paiement c'est-à-dire
le rejet par les banques d'un ordre de
paiement par chèque ou prélèvement ou
cartes sont plafonnés tout comme les
commissions d'intervention perçue en
raison des traitements des irrégularités
de fonctionnement d'un compte bancaire
depuis 2014 deux évolutions importantes
de majorités différentes entre août
en tout en outre pardon et soul
influence du droit européen qui s'est
traduite dans la transposition de la
directive du 23 juillet 2014 les
établissements bancaires sont tenues de
proposer une offre spécifique comportant
les services de base aux personnes en
situation de fragilité financière sont
alors bénéficiaires les personnes
faisant l'objet d'une procédure de
traitement de surendettement les
personnes inscrites au fichier central
des chèques en raison d'un chèque impayé
ou d'un retrait de carte bancaire par la
banque
et aux personnes en situation de
fragilité financière selon les banques
les mesures d'information ont également
été renforcées dès l'information avant
de débiter les commissions
d'intervention et présentation d'un
document d'information tarifaire
accessible en ligne gratuitement et
distingue la brochure tarifaire
il s'agit de pouvoir comparer les frais
bancaires d'un pays à l'autre
les évolutions ont aussi été lié à la
colère exprimée à l'occasion du
mouvement des gilets jaunes en 2018
le président de la république s'est
largement impliqué lorsqu'il a convoqué
les dirigeants des principales banques
et obtenu le gel des hausses des frais
bancaires en 2019
d'autres engagements ont été pris cela a
été dit mais je le rappelle le
plafonnement des frais d'incident
bancaires pour les personnes en
situation de fragilité financière à 25
euros par mois réduit à 20 euros par
mois et à 200 euros par an pour les
personnes bénéficiant de l'offre
spécifique la diffusion accélérée de
l'offre spécifique pour les clientèles
en situation de fragilité financière
comme le note notre rapporteur michel
canevet 18 mois plus tard force est de
constater que ces engagements ont été
tenus
je ne reviendrai pas sur l'article
unique de la proposition de loi le
rapporteur a été suffisamment précis
quant aux obstacles qui doivent pousser
le sénat a amendé ce texte
les discussions entre le gouvernement et
les établissements bancaires se montrent
fructueuse sans mépris et je crois que
les banques réalisent leur
responsabilité dans le climat social de
notre pays et les attentes toujours plus
forte et légitime de justice nous
croyons en revanche que des précisions
législatives peuvent intervenir à ce
titre notre groupe proposera deux
amendements
le premier visant un effort de
transparence des établissements
bancaires quant aux critères qu'ils
utilisent pour qualifier les personnes
en situation de fragilité financière qui
relève à ce stade quasiment de leur
libre appréciation et puis un second qui
repose sur le constat de la transparence
permise par le document d'information
tarifaire décliné en france par
l'application de la directive du 23
juillet 2014 n'a pas conduit à une
meilleure lisibilité pour les français
tandis que disparaît progressivement
l'extrait standard des tarifs nous
proposons donc que les banques publient
dans les documents uniques les frais
liés aux douze services de base et rien
d'autre en complément du document
d'information tarifaire qui l'aurait et
qui lui y est exposé exhaustif nous
accueillons par ailleurs avec beaucoup
d'intérêt les propositions du rapporteur
michel calvet il les a détaillées nous
reviendrons dans le débat je veux dire à
ce stade si évidemment nous partageons à
la fois le constat du rapporteur et des
pistes pour assurer une protection
effective et une meilleure transparence
ce sont de bonnes propositions et elles
doivent nous servir et vous servir
madame la ministre à nourrir la
réflexion sur ce sujet enfin chers
collègues je ne peut que nous rappeler
collectivement la complexité de ces
problèmes
les transformations à l'oeuvre la crise
sanitaire a accéléré la fin de la
monnaie sonnante et trébuchante des
ferrailleurs du max de max au profit
d'un relèvement du paiement sans contact
par carte ou par smartphone mais elle a
aussi rappelé à tous que nombreux sont
nos concitoyens exclus de ces outils
je pense par exemple aux files
d'attentes devant les postes pour leur
droit à bénéficier d'allocations de
solidarité face à cette étrange affaire
il faut travailler à des solutions qui
sans doute ne relève pas de la loi quant
au développement d'applications
numériques européennes est sûre pour une
utilisation sur smartphone la politique
est une pratique créatrice nous dit
quand ils eussent castoriadis alors
madame lise créons ainsi chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion à paroles
et éric bocquet pour le groupe crc e
pour six minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs chers collègues
d'abord je tiens à saluer l'initiative
de nos collègues du groupe socialiste et
républicain d'amener au débat ici en
séance la question du plafonnement des
frais bancaires
ce texte était très pertinent dès le
départ mais il est encore davantage
aujourd'hui dans le contexte que nous
connaissons
il s'agit effectivement d'un vrai sujet
dont l'origine est pas tout à fait
récente d'ailleurs ainsi selon une étude
sérieuse reprise par un quotidien un
quotidien économique sérieux il ya
quelques mois on a révélé des chiffres
absolument astronomiques sur l'évolution
des frais bancaires c'est le cabinet
sémaphores conseil qui a étudié
l'évolution des tarifs sur un panel
représentatif de 18 banques depuis 2010
banque nationale régionale mutualisent
des banques en ligne sur ces dix années
les banques ont mis l'accent on le sait
sur une stratégie de numérisation des
services l'objectif étant de globalement
diminuer les prix des services réalisée
via internet et d'augmenter les tarifs
en agence ainsi les frais de
consultation de compte à distance qui
était encore payant pour environ 70% des
banques du panel en 2010 sont désormais
gratuits partout dans le même temps la
gratuité des virements sur internet
s'est généralisée alors que les mêmes
opérations réalisées en agence ont vu
leur coût moyen augmenter de 28%
l'étude évoque un tarif par exemple de 3
euros 70 pour un virement toujours en
agence
la mise à disposition de fonds coûte
aujourd'hui 61 % de plus qu il y a dix
ans et les frais de location de coffres
forts ont progressé de 14% avec une
facture moyenne de 99 euros
toujours selon cette étude les frais de
tenue de compte sont désormais facturés
dans le panel concerné 17 euros 0,6
centime par an en moyenne contre 1 euros
43 10 ans plus tôt nous sommes sur des
chiffres faibles évidemment mais sa
réalise quand même une hausse
vertigineuse de 1193 % en dix ans les
banques ne baisse pas les prix des
cartes non plus assez coûteuse pour
beaucoup d'entre elles jusqu'à 3 20 325
euros par an pour une carte visa
infinite excuser la publicité en 2018 et
dont les cotisations annuelles ont
progressé de 5 et demi à 14 8% en disant
voilà le contexte général ces sommes
pourront paraître dérisoire à des gens
qui n'ont pas de difficulté en fin de
mois mais ces montants viennent grever
on le sait sensiblement les moyens
limités de nos concitoyens les plus en
difficulté selon les associations de
consommateurs 78% des personnes en
situation d'endettement ont bénéficié
d'aucun plafonnement et 91 % des clients
touchant moins de 1800 euros de revenus
est payant plus de 40 euros de frais
pour incidents par mois n'ont pas non
plus bénéficié du plafonnement à 25
euros sur lequel les banques s'étaient
engagées
certains feraient pareil par ailleurs à
nos yeux sont totalement injustifiées
ceux par exemple imputés lors de la
saisie à tiers détenteur véritable
double peine qui proviendrait selon nous
interdire citons encore le rejet de
prélèvement facturé 20 euros alors que
son coût administratif n'est en réalité
que de quelques centimes autant
d'opérations qui viennent alimenter le
montant de 6 milliards et demi d'euros
cité par notre collègue dans l'exposé
des motifs de la proposition de loi
certes la fédération bancaire française
semble contesté ce chiffre ce qui vous
l'admettrez mes chers collègues peut
paraître surprenant pour des
professionnels du chiffre quotidien qui
doivent à mon avis être capable de
comptabiliser ces millions d'opérations
chaque année faudrait-il une commission
d' enquête parlementaire pour obtenir ce
chiffre
un premier bilan établi fin 2019
montrent que globalement le principe du
gel des frais bancaires a été appliquée
par la majorité des banques
une analyse détaillée d'ailleurs devrait
être rendue très prochainement c'est
monsieur villeroy de galhau qui en
parlait il ya donc eu quelques
exceptions notables
sans doute faudra-t-il exercer une
certaine vigilance quant à l'évolution
des tarifs sur l'année en cours
il faudrait absolument éviter une forme
de rattrapage du gel en 2019 toute
augmentation serait socialement et
moralement inacceptable et c'est là où
la force d'une loi serait la bienvenue
la pandémie en cours nous le savons a
des effets économiques énormes et dans
ce contexte les millions de français
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté serait
particulièrement exposées à ce risque
l'action du gouvernement pour contrer
ces effets nous semble aujourd'hui
insuffisamment volontariste et des
propositions des banques souvent trop
complexes
ouah restreinte d'où notre accord avec
le présent texte proposant un
encadrement globale de tous les frais
bancaires
le plafonnement ici permet ici proposée
permet de laisser une marge de manoeuvre
assez large de négociations entre le
secteur bancaire et le gouvernement
puisque c'est plafonnement seront
décidées par décret et gardent la forme
actuelle de plafonnement par mois et par
opération
même si un plafonnement obligatoire par
an serait selon nous le bienvenu
permettre à différents instances comme
la banque de france et les présidents
des conseils départementaux d'enjoindre
les banques de proposer à certaines
personnes l'offre spécifique
renforcerait la visibilité de cette
option et du statut de fragilité
financière appliquée aujourd'hui de
manière inégalitaire selon les
établissements et qui mériterait d'être
mieux définis
la croissance soutenue des frais
bancaires sur les dernières années et
les stratégies de contournement des
banques pour compenser les plafonnements
partiel existants sont une véritable
plaie sociale à 300 les inégalités
faisant des clients une variable
d'ajustement pour réaliser des marches à
l'heure où les taux sont à la baisse
alors que les banques devraient être à
leur service
réglementer davantage de secteurs
bancaires incitera les banques à limiter
les coûts de gestion liés aux
irrégularités et des encouragera en tout
cas c'est ce que nous visons à mieux
accompagner les personnes en difficulté
financière plus que réglementer nous
défendons des règles de sanction des
établissements ne respectant pas les
plafonnements et des instances comme
l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution et l'observatoire de
l'inclusion bancaire doivent être
mobilisés pour aller évidemment vers
plus de transparence nous voterons pour
cette proposition de loi de bon sens qui
invite à une tarification responsables
des banques et à une meilleure réclusion
bancaire je vous remercie
voilà pour ces débats au sénat sur la
proposition loi renforçant le
plafonnement des frais bancaires un
texte déposé par les sénateurs
socialistes c'est la fin de cette
émission en séance merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain rendez vous d'information
politique et parlementaire notre
émission allons plus loin de débats et
d'analysé présenté par rebecca fitoussi
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat
[Musique]